PRIYANKA VERGARDIA:
Hey, it's Priyanka.
So far, we've looked at how
Critter Junction launched
and globally scaled an
app on Compute Engine.
Today, let's learn how they
can make their social critter
app more scalable by gracefully
replacing failed instances.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With their growing
daily active users,
we help them set up
autoscaling and global load
balancing to handle
globally distributed
and constantly rising traffic.
But to keep their users from
risking their daily game
streaks, they need to make
sure their app is available all
the time without interruptions.
So today, let's focus
on helping them set up
high availability, or HA.
We know that managed instance
groups provide features
such as autoscaling, regional
multiple zone deployments,
autohealing, and auto updating.
We covered the autoscaling
and regional deployments
in the last episode.
So check it out to learn
more about global scaling.
Today, let's focus on
autohealing and auto updates.
Autohealing helps proactively
identify and replace
the unhealthy instances--
the ones that are
not responding--
with the healthy ones.
And the auto update feature
helps update the instances
without disrupting the service.
Let's focus on
autohealing for a bit.
First, we create a
health check, which
not only detects whether the
machine is running or not,
but also detects
application-specific issues
such as freezing,
crashing, or overloading.
If an instance is
deemed unhealthy,
new instances are created by
the managed instance group.
Let's see how autohealing
works in action.
In Google Cloud Console,
I have the project
from the previous
episode opened here.
First, we will create a health
check in Compute engine.
Give it a name.
Protocol is HTTP.
And let's say the
path is /health.
It can be any path you
decide for your health check.
In our demo app, we added
code that ensures that /health
returns a 200 OK
response when healthy,
and HTTP 500 internal
server error when unhealthy.
Now for setting up health
criteria, set check interval
to 10, which means
every 10 seconds
the service will be
probed for health.
Set timeout to
five, which means we
wait for maximum five seconds
for a response to a probe.
Set a healthy
threshold to two, which
defines the number
of sequential probes
that must succeed
for the instance
to be considered healthy.
And finally, set an
unhealthy threshold
to three, which defines the
number of sequential probes
that must fail for the instance
to be considered unhealthy.
And then create.
As a best practice, you want a
health check to be conservative
so you don't preemptively
delete and recreate instances.
Now, let's go to
our instance group
we created in the last episode
and add a health check to it.
Select the health check with
an initial delay of 90 seconds.
Ideally, this
initial delay should
be long enough for
the instance to be
fully running and ready
to respond as healthy.
Let's have some fun with this
and simulate failures now.
For that, we go
to the VM instance
and click on external IP
and make it unhealthy.
Wait for the autohealer
to take action,
and we will see that the green
check mark next to the instance
turns into a spinner indicating
that the autohealer has started
rebooting that instance.
One of the other concerns
when it comes to HA
is applying updates
to the instances
without impacting the service.
Managed instance
groups allow you
to control the speed and
scope of the update rollout
to minimize disruptions
to your applications.
You can also perform
partial rollouts, which
allows for canary testing.
Let's see that in action now.
On our instance group, we see
this rolling update button.
Click on that.
Word "rolling" means it
is for gradual updates.
We will add a second
template for canary testing
and select target size as 20%.
This means we want to
send 20% of the traffic
to the new instances
for canary testing.
Now, update mode is
by default proactive,
which means Compute
Engine actively schedules
actions to apply the
requested updates to instances
as necessary.
In many cases, this often
means deleting and recreating
instances proactively.
You can choose to perform
an opportunistic update
if a proactive update is
potentially too disruptive.
An opportunistic update is
only applied when you manually
initiate the update
on selected instances
or when new instances are
created by the managed instance
group.
Max surge means how
many more instances
are you willing to spin up
as a part of this update?
The higher value here
speeds up the update,
but costs more for
the new instances.
So it is a trade-off
between cost and speed.
Max unavailable
and min wait time--
I will keep them as zero,
but these parameters
are used to control how
disruptive the update is
to your service and to control
the rate at which the update is
deployed.
Through our help setting up
two high availability features
within managed instance
groups, Critter Junction
has a much more resilient
architecture now.
Autohealing proactively
defies unhealthy insurgencies
and heals them.
And auto update
updates instances
without disrupting the service.
Stay tuned to find
out what more is
in store for Critter Junction.
And remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]